alright guys grab the nearest comfy
chair and brace yourselves because metal
gear solid 5 news is here except it's
not quite here yet it will be on
Wednesday when perpetual game teasers
Konami finally reveal what's waiting at
the end of their new countdown timer I'm
mark Walton and this is gamespot news
that's right folks konami has published
a 48-hour countdown clock on it metal
gear solid 5 website implying that the
publisher is ready to make a significant
announcement regarding the game the
seiko countdown timer suggest that the
announcement will be made on Wednesday
March the 4th at six a.m. pacific time
which is 2 p.m. for those lovely people
in the UK for now konami has left no
clear indication with regards as to what
the announcement could be however the
release date is still a mystery so hey
maybe it's that who knows last we heard
series creator Hideo Kojima said abroad
launched either metal gear solid 5
stating that the project was scheduled
to ship at some stage in 2015 for now we
can but speculate will the game see a
release date this side of Christmas your
big boss continued his flirtation with
e-cigarettes and when we finally get to
levels of Barsoom during cutscenes
answers to these questions and more
coming this wednesday maybe
you